okay
for people joining this live stream we
are talking about
bio-molecular sequences and the
late stages of getting this ready for
version 12.2
of wolfram language right what are we
looking at today
well we should survey a couple of the
string functions
make sure you're okay with it
yeah something like string match queue
and string take
and i think uh
string position would be a good sample
set you know
i think this should be under
generalizations and extensions
this in the documentation
i think this is so niche compared to
what people usually use string length
for
that's great
and how do you object to that idea well
i mean we've
yeah well right well given the small
number of examples
i mean we've generally tried to avoid it
because there's no scope actually
right it's not in basic examples okay
fine yeah
well i'm not going to object to it so
much i think it could go yeah okay fair
enough
right i i thought as the last example in
the scope since it is
documented in a note it makes sense for
it to be
fat you know fair ffff should we have it
in the seal so should we have anything
in the seal cells
i think not i would also think kind of
like if you take this viewpoint it
easily explodes
yeah okay fine that's not okay what's
the other one i should look up
a string match queue
uh breathing probably michael always me
his wild card wild dash card i would
have thought it was just wild card
smooshed
it's probably smooshed we i
i don't know i would just smoosh with
over time
yeah i figured
dqa will fix it if it if it's wrong so
i think this is fine i mean this is
clearly uh
you know yeah i think this is good right
here's a question that i have okay i was
going to say that string
take and string position are sort of to
uh so string position is at the top of
that group and then string take is yeah
up there
so right this needs to say uh
something slightly different
well it will return a bio sequence right
um but i could just have that
applies well it might well it not well
it might return a list of biosequences
depending on the spec
but it doesn't return pure strings horse
things
that's true
i could should say
um
and
how do we want to say this
i don't want to say this um
how about something like this
makes sense or
what about yielding a modified
biosequence
it might not tell you it might not be
modified
yeah that's correct
um okay string position was the other
one you wanted to talk about
right um
i have a question is there a generic
visualization for biosequences
do we have a biosequence viewer not yet
is that in development
when we have the secondary structure
we'll also be
using some of the methods we have an
alpha to visualize that
no i understand that but right now we
could imagine
a viewer that allows you to just look at
i mean i think i think we should design
that i mean i think it's a it's
something which is both
a static you know here's a plot of the
thing and something which has some
degree of dynamic capability
so i mean would it be just a like a
linear kind of graph plot
kind of thing or yeah i mean just like
you know ncbi has had these tools for
millions of years where you can just
look at sequences and you can look at
alignments and so on
now there's a person like at our summer
school or summer camp who wrote a pretty
nice
sequence alignment plot function that
i'm sure is in the function repository
i mean i i think that's just a
in other words you know all what we
haven't i mean look
for many purposes probably that's not
necessary for many purposes it's just
like get the sequence
you know as a programmatic thing and be
happy i'm just i'm just raising it as a
point i hadn't really thought about it
properly
now we have looked at various
visualizations and we want to have some
okay oh interesting john
lefty's futurized for some reason um
okay right
why does it say will search when just
searches
okay
now it's a wild card without anybody in
the wild
i mean
yeah i think the middle one is is sort
of obsolete
and and well maybe that's why he wanted
you to choose between
the set the second and third futurized
notes
go wrap around
i think the third note is slightly
better what do other people think
well i i agree but i also wrote the
third one so i'm a bit biased
i have no problem with the phone anybody
else object i vote for silt
okay sounds great i'll create that
oh for god's sake why is this set wrong
why is this set for 12 1
i don't understand how docutools fails
to do this correctly
it does for me so i don't know if it ha
it's remembering something or if you
keep doing it it keeps on doing this
future keeps on going to i mean
yeah well if somebody can report that it
will be helpful and
obviously i've gotten this wrong here so
this has to be fixed okay
um yeah i'll fix it okay all right
what's next we should definitely
have a look at one new function because
last week when we discussed that
you will not so in favor of the list
output
we had a short discussion about the
durability of the reverse operation
and and it's actually not possible so
the reverse operation
can't be represented this way at least
not in a one-to-one manner
so if you go up one of the new functions
on top of the page of the guide page one
has now the list at the end that
you're okay with this one okay
okay biosequence
points out there's something called
rosalind which seems to have a
a whole that's interesting that's a good
idea we should make our version of this
so get started with programming for
bioinformatics it's a good idea
please look at it okay john michael et
cetera yeah
yep okay okay
um i'll bring in carlos i know he uses
it
good yeah write it write a tutorial
thing
um don't start it
but it's not yet complete okay sorry now
now um
yep so there's bio
sequence reverse translate list
because like the one direction can be
done through
wild cards this reaction can't be done
okay so which which direction okay so
we're talking about
biosequence back translate list okay
given the peptide where could it come
from
even with meta characters you still need
multiple representations
right okay so you're saying
biosequence translate
translates two peptides and there's a
unique way to do that that better be a
unique way to do that or we wouldn't run
so um
okay but the back translate
and i agree it has to it um
well i think that's not a crazy name i
think it's not crazy given what it is i
mean that's a
that is
i mean can you back translate to rna as
well
why not i would guess so i mean between
dna and rna that's
just oh sorry if i'm wrong it's yeah
it's just by convention
but you could go to the rna right
oh yeah if we then say biosequence
transcribe then you have rna right away
so we can get from any type to any type
i see but so you go to back to dna and
then to rna from the dna
yeah that's right so the only other name
that we had possible
we don't do this kind of thing no we
don't do this if we're gonna
we have done it in various places
all right if we could but we have fable
okay
where else have we done this
okay there's a question from dan on our
livestream it's a good question
is this pipeable into genomic alignments
i think it is right i mean this list is
the genomic alignment
can okay what do i do here if i if i go
let's say i go from a peptide here
um i don't know i don't know my peptides
well enough but i mean something like
this
oh my gosh what's it doing what is it
doing
why was it why was it grabbing it oh
this is the initial loading
why is what's the why doing here
what's going on here why is there a y in
the
i mean i thought this this it tries to
minimal
length version of this
what happens if i want the full version
i mean you apply
on the sequence here you map biosecret
instances over this
why doesn't this have an option to give
you
okay so let's say i say biosequence
instance but
if i do alignment what happens what
happens to
um sequence alignment when it deals with
wild card
bases do you understand my question
yes if if you don't give it an option it
it won't align them but there's an
option so that it will respect similar
degenerate bases
so you can have it either way
i'm sorry say that again
if if if
yeah i say there's an alignment
here and i go for example let's say i go
let's pick a particular one of these and
let's let's go
biosequence instances
of this
oh boy that gets big doesn't it
with exponentially large that's why we
thought it's a good idea
to return white cards as much as
possible well you're right
okay i i retract my statement that
there's a point in going directly
if even there's something this small
explodes this big it's hopeless
okay so now if i do sequence alignment
so let me do the very naive thing of can
i sequence align all of these together
no unfortunately it's only pairwise
right now
why why can't we generalize it
but look look look i mean sequence
alignment the way it works
is right if i say does it take i've
forgotten what it takes
um okay it's it's a verags thing so
so it takes i thought we'd always plan
to make it multi
multi you know whatever um
now its return form is completely
generalizable to the multi case
right no
yes yes
you just take that sub sequence there
look this is
everybody agrees you're just a string if
there's any disagreement
so you list them all yeah you list them
all okay
in in in the generally case it could it
could look like this for example that
that sub list
it could be something like this
i i see what you mean yeah so if one of
them is different you still get large
results
that's correct well i mean i see so so
the point is you're not combining
these but i don't think there's any way
to combine those right because the order
matters
for sure
i don't think i mean i have to say my
uses of the sequence alignment thing
over the last
decade or more i found it pretty usable
actually
and it's pretty clear which which thing
is in which sequence and so on
i don't know if there's any other diff
structure that we can return because i
mean that's a
as a general problem of returning a diff
like notebook diff for example
what should it look like okay i
typically uh replace the list
by column and the whole thing in a row
and i feel it's very readable
oh i hadn't even thought of that that's
a good idea
um so
you're saying i say row of this and then
i say in the
in i map well what happens if i map
column onto this whole thing
that might actually also work
well but for a kind of goofiness though
so you need column of
flatten off slot
enough clearly of slot
that's moderately beautiful
um
and it could probably get some vertical
creative idols if it wants to be
beautiful and in the grid and so on
yeah i know but this is the kind of
thing that we had planned for for a
visualization of this okay but but the
question is
um uh
okay there's a question here from nick
one subrevo
result may be empty in here
yes that's a that's just that that is
exactly right it can be a null string
can be a zero length string that's
perfectly okay
um okay there's a couple of questions
here from dan
um comment here perhaps this would be
better to back translate to rna and
align to a transcriptome build
so this is in the back translate list
question here
you made the statement that it's
conventional translate to dna i i don't
know that
a lot of times people will because
the uh the sequencing machinery is
for even when you hit or you're looking
at kind of the transcriptome it's handy
to use
the like with kind of the pc these those
sequencing machines
they'll kind of uh be matching against
kind of dna samples and so often you're
the reason why you're
showing a pcr for example but you're not
i mean
when you run an aluminum machine does it
the illumina
device in in in the wild returns
dna does it by default return dna
sequences
i suspect it does i don't know whether
there's a big example that's my
understanding yeah
that might be your expertise yes
what's the answer yes it returns dna
okay and there's no big switch that says
you know i'm dealing with a prokaryote
and it has and
make things you know return use instead
of t's and things
or is there or just just returns or what
no i guess it does that it will but it
always it's always returning
yeah it turns the dna forward and they
figure
that folks can transcribe it as they
need yeah
okay can we go back well
yeah i want to go back to the rough page
but if there's still more on this
there's a little bit more on this okay
so um
the use case dan is saying with the use
case of having a mass spec run
i'm wanting to know the rna transcript
it is derived from
thus eliminating much of the
multi-mapping back to the genome
i see
now i mean just to understand
yes okay i think that's a somewhat i
think that's a specialized piece of code
from my understanding of that i just
want to watch this do its thing if i say
this
and i say molecular weight for example
why doesn't that autocomplete
i don't even know what it says do i say
molecular mass here
okay well that's beautiful but why
didn't it auto complete
good question well um
i mean that requires special code that
right because it's not uh no i know but
that's a standard thing in the
autocomplete system
that to auto complete a sub value like
this
just just submit it they know how to do
it
make sense sure
um
okay okay
ref page right so
uh i you know this note about the
ncbi syntax yeah i'm just not buying
this i'm sorry
right i mean we don't define what the
smile syntax is
on uh on molecule and we don't
i mean we've already made several
references to ncbi so i'm not sure
uh you know maybe the first time we
mentioned ncbi we should spell it out
just for in you know clarity
but i'm not sure that we should but i
don't understand
this i mean because you know i go to the
ncbi page right
and i'm looking at okay this this is you
know
random table six but now
i don't understand what is this what do
i say here
you take the 64 length string and use
this as an argument
which like 64 string
this first one
okay i would never have figured that out
why can't i just give the ncbi number
what happened to the numbers six through
seven and eight
did they go extinct
i mean it looks like there's just a
number here
science moved on yeah
but i mean why don't we allow people to
just give the translation table number
yeah
why don't we just give allow them to say
you know ncbi number
oh given ncbi i think that's implemented
we yeah we did we do
the challenge is is that
there are some chemical contexts that
aren't even in the standard table
where translation does a specialized
thing
that they need to edit for there's one
like you know translation that only
happens to happen if selenium is around
of all
of all things and so it's not associated
with a particular organism
and and so what does that have to do
with that
circumstances i i understand but they've
got a list of translation tables they're
numbered
you know one through roughly 33.
why not support that number here
well i don't think it belongs in that
table i think this note is in the
completely wrong right because this is
about
translation tables not start and stop
behavior right
this note here but this is about
translation tables this is what this is
no no no
but but the table right above that note
is not about translation tables
the note above the table and the ref
page is about start and stuff
okay okay so we've got two different
issues here okay
okay standard code one contains two
pieces of information
right the aas from the beginning and the
starts here is that correct
right what does this mean
that that no what does this mean what
does this line mean
is that starts here correspond to our
start argument
that's right that's right so if uh
if or you know tt let's see here
uh i guess g
is seen that means that for the in this
parent
for this system if we know it's a start
codon it's starting with m
until we find life on europa which uses
you know
which happens to use dna but with seven
start codons or something
all okay
so we're good and it's a single start
codon
okay to get this table how do we do it
from what we have
you understand my question
right so so we we provide that table
in the uh genetic translation table
entities
through
so if i say vertebrate mitochondrial
code
how do i get that is there linguistics
for it
did you understand my question should be
yeah there's there should be there okay
so this is uh
genetic i don't know the answer but i
know okay so genetic translation table
this is going to be all the genetic
translation tables
right and you could just use that short
name in
the in in the argument as well
i mean which short name the
the display name the display name let's
code entry
go down translation
and then see here there's okay beautiful
okay so now that form
presumably is supported codon arrow
translation yes
yes that's this thing here
but that's not start codons what are you
doing here
right this is just codons in general but
hold on hold on stephen
i keep telling you this table is not
about the translation table
this table this notes table
is about the start code on behavior
okay all right okay so then here
okay this is just not going to cut it
okay a statement like that is just
like useless well it's not useless to
people who know ncbi syntax
i i think it's very useful well the
question is what does it mean what what
is the syntax
what is the syntax
there so i mean
at that point would could you link to
those examples like from that
no no we could do that but i don't think
it's the right way to do it
okay i've got several comments here okay
first point is
if we're going with the ncbi stuff
this gtt thing could perfectly well be
an integer
which is the i think we should list out
here
how to specify gtt just like we're
specifying here
how to specify the start codon do you
see what i'm saying
yeah yeah okay so let's go through what
it needs to have in it
that table right i know what default
behavior is because that's
bizarre but that's that means
use the generic start codon for this
genetic translation table is that
correct
no it's it's i think the
well it was supposed to be uh no it's
the previous
yeah one right above the table that says
by deep second by default
okay why is that no
i don't understand why isn't that none
that is don't use a start codon
because it's not none it's conditional
i mean if you want false to be oh i
this really is automatic it depends on
the information provided on the input
given
it selects a sensible behavior all right
okay so let's go through what we want
here
so first point is
it seems to me we could have an import
format
that was called ncbi
you know genetic code or something and
that allows you to take one of those
strings
and convert that string to this
translation table
i'm not sure what you mean literally by
the word import format it's not a file
format
well it's an import string you can just
use import string
right and if you had it in a text file
you could import that file
right what does aas mean what does it
mean when it says aas
amino acids okay so these
individual terms
sorry i just i just didn't just needed
an explanation of that
i'm just not used to that thing okay
but right yeah well i'm going
to suggest right so the things which i
know are supported based on the examples
they gave me
is an entity a common name of an
entity uh this
arbitrary string business and its
index um yeah one two three four five
yes okay
okay all right
okay right so i think we need a new note
and another table translation
translation table
gtt can be specified
as follows
um so the default wait wait
get let's get very straightforward
things that you have okay
the before we even talk about anything
else
the default genetic translation table
used is the standard code
can you use automatic as the standard
code
perhaps yes yes you can use automatic
is the standard code for what for
eukaryotes whatever what what is what
what is the difference invertible oh
that's mitochondrial code okay
okay is the standard what what is what
would it be called
how can we ge
is it for the
for the alpha that's being uh released
now it's called actually just called
standard
it's it's that it's a standard name the
standard
i i understand i'm not asking that
question i'm asking if you want how is
it
yes what is a
a useful short description of the
standard code
if you ask somebody who didn't know what
it is
you'd say it's the nuclear code of macro
organisms
for most macro organisms
so i'd say the standard code for macro
organisms
no but it's for the nucleus but
okay um as a standard code
it's too complicated because it says
excluding the mitochondria and blah blah
blah blah blah
okay um okay but so so
the genetic translation table can be
given as follows
okay
um oh my god
two column actually here we can say
automatic
and then we can just say uh the standard
code
param default
let me don't need to say that okay
so now how do we represent um
so how do we represent an entity usually
um okay so hold on name
and then here we can say standard name
for a genetic translation
table entity okay
okay well all the entity itself right
so how do we do that should we just say
or entity
no we just say so on the molecule page i
i type
entity of chemical comma
entity and then the chemical forms a
link to the chemical
page
and so there probably isn't a genetic
translation or maybe there is i'm not
sure
probably just dot dot or i think so
there is such a page
yes okay maybe we should put those in
the opposite order
okay now we've got
n yep ncbi
um it's the national
i know what that i'm not worried about
that i'm worried about what uh
how to describe
and cbi genetic code number
genetic
okay next case we've got is
um
string
a-a-a-a-a
that really has to be a dot-dot type
thing
maybe no just let's say that
um ncbi
um
amino acid
translation string you should probably
say it must be 64 characters to work
um because the aaa might be misleading
yeah
i understand
length 64 ncbi
um and that's based on tuples
t c
g a no t c a g
right right
okay now the next thing we can give is
an explicit table right
like this
right we can give a code on translation
table correct
but but this is what we trust forward or
i'm confused
no no no this form here
if you wanted to give this presumably oh
i see what you mean
right so that becomes
explicit codon translation table
right okay i think this will work
okay
right now we could possibly try to fold
that one independent note
into the table let's try let's see what
we can do here
um
okay so obviously you've got to clean
this up and i don't know whether this
has to be used in other places because
this
translation table are there other
functions which use it generally
yes so we'll need to copy this
which other functions use it well
biosequence translate
um i'm not sure if there are others
that's that's
the only other one
okay all right so this is the same thing
for that
okay now start codons okay
okay what does it do with the start
codon
how does it use a start codon what is it
what does the start codon do
here
do you understand my question
yeah so the the start codon
is only used if we're given an input
that tells us it's the complete protein
if we're given just some random
peptide we don't say so in other words
the only thing we do
no no no no the only thing we do if
we're told that is we just
drop the start codon from the transcript
from the translation correct
no the only thing we do is we change the
translation of the first codon given
right there there's a special
translation that's only applicable to
start codons
and what is what does the start codon
translate into because it's not
transcribed so what does it translate
into
usually usually m
so if you look at the starts there below
the aas
you'll see so in other words
so i see so normally that will be
transcribed
as this this thing here at that
that i'm so confused here
this is amino acid l
so amino acid l transcribes to in our
back translation
transcribes to what in this code amino
acid l has
three different possibilities right
l will translate to six different things
across this table
and we can condense it down into two
using degenerate characters
okay fine fine okay okay
fine so then
but if we're in start codon mode
l will translate to m and nothing but m
is that correct
now if if we're in start codon mode m
will also
translate to the thing that l used to tr
would translate
to otherwise
what so i think he's trying to say that
at the beginning allen
m are treated the same way
is that what we're saying now if you if
you're give
if you're translating and that you're at
the beginning and you're given
the codon that would that would
typically translate to l
as selected here if it's at the
beginning instead it's translated to m
okay but you're explaining the wrong
thing because we're looking at the
function
back translate list right right
so you're explaining the other way
around right
right because this table originated on
the translate page
okay so translate page says the
codon c t
g or whatever it is if it's in the start
position will translate to m
otherwise it will translate to l correct
right right okay so let's make sure we
can explain that
on the page on the translate page
boy whoever designed this for organisms
wow
um okay so
what is it translated into by default
to what
to a peptide sequence right by default l
yeah that's right no no no no no i'm not
talking about l i'm talking about the
first
note here it was implied by the word
translate in a biosense not in a
technical okay i think we should say to
to a
should we say to a peptide sequence
that can't hurt that's good
okay so in this case this is saying
okay so this is wrong here this needs to
have something like this
and this by the way goes away
okay so this isn't quite right and has
to be separately it has to be edited but
we need to put this in here
just so we know roughly what we're going
for okay
okay so then we say
um
how does it know if it's a com okay
okay so what this says is
um
okay if a start codon
in
sequence
translate of dot dot dot comma start
start specifies
how a start codon
should be translated
look it doesn't help that this says
start and i don't think that's a good
way to say it i think we should say
start table or start spec
be better um
treats start codons
according to the specification
okay
the start specifically start codon
specification
start spec
[Music]
um
specifies
what translation
okay so this is only when that occurs at
the beginning of biosec
right that's right
okay so it needs to say that um
specifies what translation should be
used
for the first codon
in biosequence right
that's correct
okay
if no start spec
is given
right and so here here's what the
statement is
the automatic behavior is if we know
it's um beginning of approaching
then we use the default behavior
specified by
the genetic translation table right and
otherwise we do nothing right right
right right
okay don't we say
whether a special translation
should be used for the first
if no spark starts back as given
special translation
will be used only if
biosec
um
is a protein entity
or some other or some other
specification of a complete protein
okay so now we should say
the following forms oops why did that
happen
the following
forms for start spec
can be used
okay so now automatic
[Music]
um
hmm okay
use special
start codon
translation
why don't we say this whether the first
codon
in biosec should be treated
now
specifies what translation
should be used for the first codon if no
special um
the the first codon
will be treated as a start
codon
only if blah blah blah
okay
okay
i'm surprised this thing isn't an option
but it's okay okay
never treat as start codon
following forms
how to treat the first codon
in biosac
never treat us start codon
always treat
okay what the heck is this
that's uh so that you can uh give a
custom
behavior for the start codon translation
right so that's you're giving a complete
table okay so
so this would be so you don't in fact
need to give the whole table
right this is just give
a give right this is specify
the translation of the first codon
or something explicitly specify codon
explicitly specify start code on
translations
yes
okay and then we have
probably we should have that
well then we should probably do the same
thing here um
probably we should get both of these
here now
you know what i'm going to switch the
order in that first thing
and no i'm not because it's much more
likely you're going to give the ncbi
thing
so this this would this would mix two
different translation
tables
right but you already had that you
already did that
and you already said that
you already said that
i mean arguably you just leave out these
cases for this but
here because if you want to do i mean
you know you can do this let's let
people do this doesn't have
hurt right um
right i mean do we want to change the
the description of the
um of the length 64 guy because it's not
like the amino acid translation table
let's uh like start or something it's
amino acid
no no it is or is it not that's kind of
the line two from the table the starts
table
right but i'm claiming that the first
line is the amino acid translation table
so i thought you referred to the 64. no
misunderstanding
this should probably say codon
now which way round is this this is for
translate
two amino acids right so this should say
codon translation and the other way
around it should say amino acid
translation
the other way around when this appears
in back in this case
that's correct the amino acid but here
it should say codon translation table
okay did you understand what i'm saying
well in both cases what you're
specifying is the code on translations
just in
one case you're trying to i know but
they call it a so it's just um
um in both cases you're giving a string
of amino acids
okay ncbi genetic code number okay
length 64
ncbi start codon translation string
hold on
um right i mean the one thing that's a
little bit confused
slash confusing in this table is that
the first
three tell you i know so we say always
treat a start code on
um
[Music]
use how about something like that use
ncbi
genetic code number start codon
specification
right but the point i'm trying to make
is that the first three entries in the
table are
using an automatic behavior inferred
from the second argument and just saying
whether or not to apply it
and the last three i suppose are
effectively true plus
override the behavior i see what you're
saying
and and we're sort of never explicitly
saying that okay okay okay okay okay
[Music]
um
um
unless
an explicit well let's see
i think we could say the following the
following
additional formula break the previous
table the following additional forms
for start spec
can be used to override
the start codon specification
implied by
the genetic translation table
gtt and now this goes
this is hard work you know
okay do we want to add something like
the following additional forms
can be used to unconditionally
override or you know something that says
we're we're going to
yeah i say i said so it's too
to find start codon behavior
[Music]
um
how about that
i think that will work
just get rid of this
okay are you going to provide wfr
functions for handling these things i
really think that we should call it
[Music]
um
you know we should have an import format
that is this
an export format too that will take i
mean this is the low priority thing and
it can be initially a function
repository that will take
one of these translation tables and turn
it into
one of these things make sense
that sounds great by the way don't
forget
that um
yeah and there's some
some uh um keywords like initiation code
and so on um
uh okay
boy it's amazing how digital this whole
thing is
just amazing now we just need a way
of understanding uh
you know just as digital information
gives a way of understanding genetic
you know specifications of organisms now
the question is what is the generic way
of understanding
the you know reactions between molecules
between biomolecules that make organisms
go
and you know these giant metabolic
pathway charts don't really cut it
and actually our current thinking in
terms of multi-way graphs
and all these kinds of things i think is
a better formalism but anyway that's for
another day
um okay is there anything else we need
to look at here
yeah go ahead if you do have time we
have two functions
from the chemistry well i think i think
we should i think we should take a quick
look at biosequence to
the main page just to make sure uh you
know it was sort of balancing
between uh the
right um you know providing information
and you know not being a textbook
um and so we went back and forth a few
times i think
i really like having this table here
okay
and and you're and you think what about
the star what about
star and things like that shouldn't they
be in that table
is star understood by biosequence
and is that even i don't know i thought
it was
i thought it was an alternative
essentially an authentic to n
or uh star and peptide is an alternative
the stop character i should add the stop
characters that's
that's an oversight on my part
right then yeah so you see the things i
suggested we exclude
that we probably don't really need to be
a textbook and
i don't know why not why not i mean for
somebody like me
who is you know i can't remember whether
lysine is l or
whatever i i think it's useful i don't
see why we shouldn't do this i mean
clearly you can look this up in a
million other places
a peptide let us get a capital p
i mean the question is is is that the
only place it would go like in the notes
page for this i would think so
i can't see any other place it's worth
putting it
right i mean i think that's the i think
this page is the only place where we
list all the letters
i mean other than the you know the
entity page and whatnot
where it's computable yeah so we could
maybe fold this in as an
added column to one of the tables
no i wouldn't do that i would just have
this table here
but we we but don't we all right oh we
don't list them
okay no we don't we don't distort them i
think this is a good thing to do
okay
that almost begs the question should we
have something similar
for a molecule with the atomic symbols
and the atom's full names
now i think much more people note this
at least okay right
i don't know why but maybe it's just
because i know those and i don't know
all of these
i know some of these but not all of them
do do people working in this business
would they know all of these would they
just know oh that's a cue i don't care
you know
they would know it they would know why
why would they know it just because
general education or what because that's
their their field their expertise
you have to remember it's their jargon
chemistry class yeah well i i know you
have to remember this in a biochemistry
class but once you're doing
bioinformatics do you actually care that
it's glutamine
as opposed to just some random you know
uh codon that represents something
uh generally i think they do because it
tells you something about what's
happening or what
you know the properties of that part of
a protein sequence
whether it's hydrophilic hydrophobic
yeah i understand that but when you're
doing bioinformatics a lot of the time
you're just saying
you know what's that snip i see before
me type thing
and you know what's that correlated with
okay fair enough but you're telling me
okay for those sort of snaps yeah
they're a properly educated chemist
i mean about you know properly educated
person in this business would absolutely
know all of these
nice but i better memorize them it's
part of my personal self-improvement
no just like i've been learning anyway
um i'm finally as a result of my most
recent history project i'm finally
fully fluent in in transcribing
handwritten cyrillic
that's a useful absolutely useless
skill but um uh okay
um all right anything else to look at so
you say you have some chemistry things
what were they
so we have two pages molecule draw and
valence filling which
are futurized new symbols
so valence filling was the thing we
discussed previously
and it should be easy to unfuturize i
think
i thought it was fine i mean
yeah it's not a big deal it's uh
slightly obscure
for most people on that valences with
hydrogen atoms yes yes yes that's
exactly what we discussed is
this is the last version json did we not
just change the unmet to open
i thought we did i uh well okay then let
me not save this
okay it looks fine okay the other one
was what
that's an interesting one what is the
cloud support story for molecule draw
it does not work but for after 12 2 i'm
going to work with
uh with yarn to to get the
it to work so it's very
um uh saying that it works in desktop is
a debatable point of view based on my
experience
trying playing with it yesterday
what do you mean are you using the linux
machine uh
i think i was using linux at the time
but
so i i had some molecule
uh okay so
let's say let's just say that i say
molecule draw
of uh caffeine
i'm sure i would prefer something else
but okay oh wow
cool okay so now
let's say i want to substitute what's
another valence three puppy
oh no no no what's up
there's thing number one what is that
what is this so
you added a bond to the nitrogen and now
it has too many electrons
so i certainly shouldn't put its
messages there it should display its
messages in the object
right i quieted the messages so i just
pushed some changes that were merged
to 12 to two why can't why doesn't the
delete button work here
how do i delete that oh no i'm
just making bonds like crazy right and
you can make a bonds out an empty space
that
just i guess are connecting too so now
i'm
now i'm selected did noah or anybody
else look at this
yeah no so noah has helped me a lot with
this
i i i am not where's the ch4 what what
is the ch4 doing here
with delete it should go away i think
you deleted a bond instead of
the atoms let's see
okay i want to put
i want to substitute that guy how do i
substitute
so you want to change an atom so select
the atom type and then
and then all right what's another
valence two thingy sulfur
let me go i'm gonna use polonium instead
just for fun
hot stuff right
um okay
and so now if i say return
is that just produced invalid valence
for whatever
so the those mess so those messages are
quieted now
oh look at that one telonium that's
really that's very swank it's even
bigger why is it bigger
is that because it's because it has more
it has more shells right it's really
shown bigger and i never realized that
so that's cool yeah is that is that
typical
yes i think so so so there's a
um a method option for adam sy's rules i
think which we eventually want to
fold into adam's style or something
right i mean i think the fact that
the the default tool is single bond so
if i just do mal
kill draw of something uh
caffeine maybe the full one should
depend on if it starts with a blank one
or with
somebody there well what happened here
why did that not
i'm totally monumentally confused by
many things that happened here
first of all why didn't that turn into
an entity see we may not have a chemical
entity for xenon hexafluoride
how come it's recognized by molecule
then
let's see so alpha can recognize any
input chemical name and if it doesn't
correspond to a chemical entity then the
the mathematica string
is then a molecule of the name
okay i understand that that you're
taking something implementational
i'm asking why is xenon hexafluoride not
recognized
given that am i wrong that it exists
as an entity think i know where the
confusion is
so we don't have as a entity in chemical
but we do
understand it through the puzzles we
have so
the only form that we can have as a
mathematical
think representation is molecule of the
name
okay so now i mean obviously i was bug
finding here
i mean this is a very weird this
molecule does exist and i'm not
misremembering that
it does exist it does should be
octahedral shape so
the shape that was generated was not the
best
but this invalid valence
is because surveillance models doesn't
have
uh hooked up for right and
stephen can you tell that that delete
button is a delete button
because i'm on my local machine
i can't tell i think it'd be better to
have an x
thing some kind of x indication so i've
i've reached out to to noah and to ask
for a better delay yeah or or
even have this delete key fill up the
whole button i mean having just
zoomed the whole thing it's using up
like
1 9 of the total button area which just
seems
crazy right doesn't look that way to me
i mean
okay well oh well it does on linux it's
using up one ninth of the year
so that's probably a bug on linux okay
but but so
what would i expect all right so if i
return that guy
okay now in fact will it do the correct
octahedral thingy
no so it's not going to generate good 3d
coordinates for that i don't imagine
you don't need to do it silently fails
yeah it shouldn't just silently fail
what what does it have to say in that
case i can't find the 3d coordinates
yes so there is a message for not being
able to generate coordinates and so i
i can reproduce what you see there and
so i will fix that
okay
so basically it's eyes point and it's
probably true is that molecule draw is
sort of an experimental experimental
function but
it's good to have it it's really good to
have it right it's so experimental i
i plan if possible to kind of add uh
really update it through paclet uh as
yeah well that's fine but i mean i think
that
i mean if we honestly i think it doesn't
i mean for example
well now let me see if what happens if i
give um
what's a nice big molecule a ribosome
you make molecules off and then you make
a biosecret and then you get really nice
big things
did i spell that wrong
why isn't it finding cholesterol
um it might be coming up as something
for food as well as chemical
but it's pink right
to a dietary reference
okay guys this needs to be straightened
out
right incense yeah wait wait yeah okay
molecule okay fine molecule now why
again doesn't don't we have an entity
for cholesterol
that's rather swank okay now why can't i
resize this window size
why can't i resize that window
no it's a dialogue notebook
you need to ask somebody how to do it
because it needs to be doable
um right and uh oh my god there's just a
random bond there
yeah and like how do i connect two
things like i i tried to put a c
and an f in the middle of nowhere oh
what's going on
where's the ch4 coming from so you you
create
so the default tool is to to add a bond
if you click somewhere where there is no
atom
then it will add uh to like a a
an ethane fragment or an ethic why
i do because that's what that's what
other chemical drawing tools do
why is there no way to connect but
that's crazy that's very easy
if you want to connect two things like
so you have single bond selected
and then click on one atom drag to
another atom and it should make a bond
between them
oh that is not obvious
okay now well i mean how would you think
why is this this is showing hydrogens
but i show hydrogens is not true yes
i've
so i've fixed that into um so now click
redraw
so remove them and then click redraw
well no i could see it
it did the right thing there well i i
would expect it to
not actually when i if i click directly
on one
so first of all if i click in between
them i might think that it would connect
the two
yeah what's the stat plus plus is doing
the wrong thing
plus plus plus plus plus what is plus
doing
zooming in zooming in but then there's
no pan
yes i need to hook that up
well naively i thought that if i if i
put a single bond in between two things
it might connect them
also why no it created a random single
bond connecting two new
um this is not the right behavior
i mean this also doesn't have standard
notebook affordances like
like a um a magnification and so on
i think you should ask somebody who
knows front-end stuff well
how to do this i don't think this is
quite right in terms of giving you that
kind of capability
and so on um
yeah so so the notebook should be
resizable
i think so i think it should have a
magnification yeah i think so
i will find maybe other things which i'm
not yet thinking of but um
um okay can who's got a ginormous
molecule
so let's say molecule draw
of um let's say the molecule of
biosequence
yeah molecule
why can't i just directly put a
biosequence in the molecule draw
because um let's see no molecule
functions
take biosequences at the moment
why not
let's see because not every biosequence
can be converted into a molecule
why not
because we haven't hooked it up yet um
so so this i mean i mainly wanted to
what happened with this what happened
with this why did this say biosequence
i don't know maybe that's just something
that doesn't exist i don't know
let's see so i would have typed
biosequence just
cccc or something i know that but that's
not what i want to do i want i want to
put in an actual thing to see what
happens
that's a gene why don't you try
something like chemotrypsin
or trypsin
i think this is going to blow its brains
out because there's a huge gene
i mean they're definitely not made for
this yeah this is uh
all right we'll see what happens okay
fine so let's just kill it
oh it's not interruptable
guys what's it doing not interruptable
i understand it's not done for this i'll
do trypsin
if i can get this to come back to life
you need to close
or did you close the window normally and
it's now evaluating slowly or
yeah i'm just it's not opened by a
molecule drawer window it's still
grinding on this biosequence which i'm
not surprised about it's probably got a
million atoms in it
literally so that was unfair of me
i'm just curious whether there's a
molecule that works
we try to say a handful of
proteins or dna elements and it
it looks pretty okay yeah this one is
huge
this is this is unfair okay the fact
that it's uninterruptable is bad
you should look at that what
okay now you're telling me i should be a
little bit more modest and ask for
trypsin
as biosequence
well let's just do let's just do t t
a g or something what does it do if i if
i give it a wild card
the molecule should fail
that's pretty nifty
well done
okay so let me just check that
okay so if i say t
n g
what this is really badly written if i
might say so
must be resolved to represent a
biosequence to a molecule
what do you mean to represent it to
convert yes yes that should just be
convert
this should be a little bit rewritten
but
must be resolved
yeah okay fine that's fine okay but
that's quite impressive that that works
so then then if i were to take this just
for fun
and i would just say molecule plot 3d
percent one oh very nice
there it is okay
um well look molecule draw is clearly
um so it's very unconventional
in the way that it creates a dialogue
notebook blocks your kernel in your
current notebook
and then returns to it and so the doc
page
is also unconventional in that it just
shows a screenshot of the window
in the same way that the only other
function i could find that does
a similar thing was dialog input and so
that's what it is there's plenty of
other ones that do it that have
weird external you know tentacles
look i think this is a model potentially
for other things a bit like this
it it is already a temporary solution
yeah like at one point
given a molecule we wanted to represent
as such and you can switch to the
drawing mode to change it
yeah exactly it'll have an attached cell
just like just like the new attached
cell
for for i mean if i do a plot right i
get
i think i get the new attached cell
don't i
where is my friend what would happen
here
where is noah's toolbar that he's been
working on for so long
what what the heck's going on here do
you not have to wrap it in canvas
i thought so no it's supposed to come up
by default
that's supposed to come up by default in
that case
uh this toolbar is missing it's just not
well there it came up finally
yes just like just like of course just
like
you know you're very familiar with this
if i do
you know a picture
of a uh of an antelope
oh goodness sake what the heck is that
picture of an antelope
returns the city antelope no no
bad i mean it's been very impressive
what it does but it's wrong
so it can
you see this that's an attached cell
that gives you all of those
capabilities right
do you see what i'm saying yes
absolutely right
so that's what's supposed to happen for
graphics now
um
right okay we have two comments on the
live stream we should probably wrap in a
second bob was saying
be wonderful to simulate rna making
proteins and assembling itself into a
dodecahedral eye cathedral whatever
virus
how far away are we from this
i mean the fragments of it can we can we
actually make do we have like
like uh viral capsids and things like
that we must have the genes for viral
capsids
by the way i assume that we're getting
other organisms from ncbi
like our friendly you know coronavirus
so to speak in into uh
genome into the genome data stuff
are we
right now it's a self-standing wdr but
i i know for that particular thing i'm
asking for the zillions of other
organisms that have now been sequenced
when we first did this like 10 years ago
there were only a limited number of
organisms and we
we we put those in but now there are
lots and lots of organisms lots and lots
of different viruses etc etc
what are we doing with that i would
think for the
start we use service connects
okay do we have a mechanism
well we should look at that because
that's an obvious thing to want to do to
pull in
you know this particular organism
right and particularly if we have the
organism okay here's a comment if we
have the organism as an entity
we should at least align our organism
entities
to um uh
to the ncbi organism identifiers
for genome sequences doesn't make sense
absolutely um and then
you know anyway but but uh
uh dunstable is asking can i generate
peptides or full proteins
um yeah i think so uh
tauroid is asking how far away of
simulating ligand receptor interactions
okay that's for the chemistry team
comments
of let's see uh doing intra
intramolecular uh or intermolecular
interactions
is uh in a couple of versions away
what's the it's not on the radar at the
moment fair enough
okay um
all right very good okay anything else
we should cover here
oh this would be it okay jason if you
could just join my zoom when you pop
when you end here
okay okay great thanks
guys thank you people on live stream
thank you